AND WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
SEEN TEXT MESSAGES BETWEEN THE
FBI BETWEEN SENT BETWEEN PETER
STRZOK AND LISA PAGE BETWEEN
FEBRUARY AND SEPTEMBER OF 2016.
A LOT OF THEM ARE INTERESTING.
THEY DID WHAT THEY HOPED YOU
WOULDN'T DO EXPRESSING CONCERN
IF HILLARY CLINTON WOULD TAKE
REVENGE AGAINST THE FBI FOR THE
CRIME OF INVESTIGATING HER.
IN EXCHANGE FROM FEBRUARY OF
2016, AGENT PAGE TOLD AGENT
STRZOK, ONE MORE THING, SHE MAY
BE OUR NEXT PRESIDENT.
THE LAST THING YOU NEED IS US
LOADED FOR BEAR.
DO YOU THINK SHE CARES IT'S MORE
DOJ SO POLITICAL CONCERNS WERE
ATOP OF MIND AS THEY
INVESTIGATED THIS POLITICIAN,
HILL
HILAR
HILARY
HILARY CL
HILARY CLIN
WE HAVE A CONGRESSMAN HERE TO
JOIN US.
ARE WE READING TOO DEEPLY INTO
>> UM, I DON'T THINK SO.
YOU READ THAT IN ISOLATION.
IF YOU READ ALL THE TEXTS IT'S
CLEAR THEY DID NOT WANT HER
CHARGE.
TRUMP TO BE THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AND CONCEDED
THROUGH THE TEXTS THEY DID
THINGS DIFFERENTLY IN THIS
INVESTIGATION FROM ANY OTHER
INVESTIGATION THEY WERE A PART
OF.
>> Tucker: WHAT I DON'T
UNDERSTAND IS EVEN IF YOU'RE
WATCHING AT HOME AND THINK I
WANTED HILARY TO WIN TOO AND I
WANTED DONALD TRUMP TO WIN TOO,
SHOULDN'T WE BE CONCERNED THEY
WERE WORRIED ABOUT THE POLITICAL
ELEMENT OF THE INVESTIGATION?
THAT'S NOT SUPPOSED TO HAPPEN,
IS IT?
>> YOU MAY REMEMBER, AS I DO,
JAMES COMEY THEY DON'T GIVE A
WITT ABOUT POLITICS.
OUR FRIENDS ON THE LEFT SAYING
THESE ARE TEXTS BETWEEN TWO
LOVERS.
ANYBODY ELSE IS WATCHING.
THIS IS THE UNVARNISHED TRUTH
HOW THEY VIEWED HER, HIM AND THE
INVESTIGATION AND HOW THEY
WANTED IT TO TURN OUT.
KEEP IN MIND, TUCKER, ALL OF
THIS IS DONE BEFORE SHE WAS EVER
INTERVIEWED.
SO THE FIX WAS IN.
UNFORTUNATELY BEFORE THEY EVEN
INTERVIEWED THE TARGET OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
>> Tucker: WHAT DOES IT TELL YOU
PRESIDENT SHE'D PUNISH THE CHIEF
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY FOR
INVESTIGATING HER.
>> IT'S EITHER THAT OR ANOTHER
REASONABLE CONSTRUCTION IS SHE'D
AWARD THE DOJ THINKING IT'S MORE
DOJ LAWYERS CONCLUDING SHE
SHOULD NOT BE CHARGED RATHER
THAN FBI.
THAT'S HOW I READ IT, SHE'D GIVE
KEEP IN MIND IN THE TEXTS, IT
DOESN'T SEEM ANYONE WANTED HER
CHARGED BEFORE THEY READ WHAT
SHE WAS GOING TO TAKE AND DOJ
WOULD GET MORE CREDIT THAN THE
BUREAU.
>> Tucker: YOU'VE TAKEN AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF ABUSE AS THE
CHANNEL FOR DARING TO REPORT THE
NEWS AS IF ASKING QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE BEHAVIOR OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL
UNPATRIOTIC.
>> NO ONE HAS MORE RESPECT THAN
LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR US.
LIFE.
THESE TEXTS BREAK MY HEART.
YOU KNOW, THINK BACK TO OTHER
IMPORTANT CASES IB
IMPORTANT CASES IN
IMPORTANT CASES IN O
IMPORTANT CASES IN OUR
IMPORTANT CASES IN OUR C
IMPORTANT CASES IN OUR COU
IMPORTANT CASES IN OUR COUNT
IMPORTANT CASES IN OUR COUNTRY
AS A HISTORY.
MARK FURMAN GOT IN TROUBLE FOR
RACIAL EPITHETS UTTERED EARLIER
IN HIS CAREER.
THAT'S HOW SERIOUSLY WE TAKE
BIAS.
I DON'T KNOW WHY THE LEFT CAN'T
NEVER HAVE BEEN PART OF
INVESTIGATING HER CASE.
>> Tucker: YOU WOULD THINK MOST
FBI AGENTS ARE LIBERAL.
THAT.
DON'T SEEM TO HAVE AN INTEREST
IN THAT RIGHT NOW, WHY?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T LIKE POLITICAL BIAS
MANIFESTING IT IN A POLITICAL OR
BANK ROBBERY CASE.
THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY,
POLITICALLY CHARGED CASE AS WAS
AND IS THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
BIAS IS EVEN MORE IMPORTANT IN A
STRAINING TO MINIMIZE THE